porque me castiga y así
normal de hoy
hola buenas tardes
primero que todo muchas gracias por
estar aquí compartiendo este momento
conmigo
bueno yo estoy aquí para contarles que
estamos todos hoy en día en este minuto
siendo parte de una película que está
haciendo grabada ahora estamos todos
actuando todos dirigiendo y todos
produciendo esta gran película que
podríamos llamar la película universal
yo le llamo así porque así es como yo
entiendo el mundo
yo hago cine y a través de la cámara es
como yo exploro en el fondo
pero es sólo una metáfora para ello
hablarles de una idea que tuve que le
llamé meta cerebro ya esta idea me vino
hace unos años mientras yo estudiaba
cine en nueva york' y pasó que un día yo
necesitaba hacer un gran cambio en mi
vida y de alguna forma sabía cuál era el
camino entonces sabía lo que tenía que
hacer pero no no sabía de dónde venía
ese impulso entonces yo estaba hablando
con una vez mejor amiga estamos en la
calle y quería explicarle lo que me
estaba pasando
entonces le dije como liz y lo que pasa
es que
siento esto como una gran cosa arriba de
mi cabeza que no sé lo que es pero eso
lo que me está diciendo lo que tengo que
hacer y mi amiga como me quiere mucho se
puso muy seria y mi hijo como ajá y yo
le dije como bueno no sé es como que
siento como un cable conector medio
transparente que me está conectando con
un metal cerebro
y ella nuevamente lo hizo como si como
me quiso entender me quiso apoyar porque
yo en ese minuto estaba pasando por algo
más o menos grande entonces así partió
en el fondo le puse este nombre para yo
poder explicarle a mi familia ya mi
amigo lo que estaba pasando por mi
cabeza
entonces voy a empezar esta es la como
ustedes vieron el tráiler este es de mi
cortometraje y todo el cielo con el ojo
de la vaca muerta como yo trabajo yo
escribo guiones y luego dirijo las
películas a veces edito pero luego de
ello escribir en el guión hago un
storyboard que se llama como algo así y
paso que esta fue la primera imagen que
me llegó del cortometraje
y sentí que tenía que empezarlo con este
ojo y lo primero que hice fue dibujarlo
pero sin saber qué iba a pasar después
para mí esto era como la ventana hacia
el cortometraje que luego se hizo real
no se hizo película
bueno y ahora para hablarles realmente
del meta cerebro todos tenemos uno de
estos no es cierto que es en el fondo lo
que manda indicaciones a todo el cuerpo
para que podamos funcionar para que
podemos vivir en el día a día muchas
personas dicen que
es un poco lo que hacen los directores y
las directoras de cine que en el fondo
mandar a todo el mundo en el set a mí
siempre me dijeron que era mandona pero
yo lo veo como guiar a gente
pero nuestro cerebro también nos da un
espacio para imaginar para tener ideas
/ yo
vine aquí a decirles que hay veces que
estas ideas no vienen de aquí no vienen
de nosotros sino que vienen de esa cosa
que está más arriba ya entonces qué
pasaría si ahora en este minuto las
ideas que ustedes están teniendo yo les
digo ustedes están solo decodificando
están bajando información que nos viene
de aquí sino que viene de otro lado
esto pongámosle que es el medio cerebro
es así como yo lo imagino esté solamente
en mi idea esta es mi verdad podría
decir y aquí es donde convive en el
fondo todo lo que necesitamos para hacer
esta meta película está los personajes
están la trama está el romance es tan
bueno ahí pueden ver hay un mapita por
ahí puede estar las cosas las pistas
para que los personajes los
protagonistas encuentren el tesoro por
ejemplo están pasando muchas cosas en
algo que yo veo como este gran cerebro
ya y donde aparecen imágenes donde
aparecen sonidos aromas que no siempre
están muy visibles pero que en el fondo
está todo ahí para nosotros está todo
ahí para que nosotros sepamos más de
nosotros mismos y del mundo que nos
rodea
pero tengo que agregar que nosotros
tenemos una especie de filtro ya que yo
le llamo filtro o radar ya porque
primero filtramos información y ese
filtro tiene que ver con nuestros genes
como como nacimos donde cuando que quien
es como nuestro cuerpo
cómo funciona nuestra mente pero también
todo nuestro entorno nuestras
experiencias quiénes nos fuimos formando
como quiénes somos cuál es nuestra
personalidad
ese es el filtro y el radar que es al
mismo tiempo porque la información sube
y baja
es lo que nos permite a nosotros
encontrar las cosas que nosotros
necesitamos yo por ejemplo como mientras
escribo guiones estoy siempre
localizando cosas que me sirvan a contar
mi historia
pero ya van a ver que también lo uso
para la vida no solamente para las
películas aunque a veces son lo mismo
bueno tengo que hacer ahora un pequeño
filtro porque esta idea que yo estoy
hablando no envía ya por lo tanto podría
decir que esta teoría no es mía nunca
fue mía porque si seguimos la lógica que
yo estoy hablando vino desde otro lado
y bueno no es coincidencia que hoy en
día en el internet se hable de la nube
y muchos autores muchas personas han
hablado de esto solamente que le han
puesto distinto nombre o no le han
puesto ningún nombre pero ha aparecido a
través de su trabajo algunos de ustedes
me imagino que conocen el concepto de
inconsciente colectivo de carl jung y si
nos vamos incluso más atrás ya los
griegos
lo que decía aristóteles lo que decía
platón y muchas de sus ideas tienen que
ver con este con este espacio donde
conviven las ideas universales
y yo para me puse aquí algunos algunos
artistas que me han influenciado de
forma muy importante como lo es borges
dalí cineastas como luis buñuel maya
deren y que trabajaron mucho con los
códigos de los sueños por ejemplo y
también puse aquí a un gran cineasta
david lynch que hace este mismo
una analogía similar pero él usa peces
las ideas son peces y nosotros vamos a
pescar este gran mar o gran lago y ahí
están las ideas en separados y unidos
hacia nosotros pero no vienen de nuestra
cabeza
entonces aquí tenemos un poco en este
dibujo todas estas cosas que estoy
hablando aquí yo le llamo bueno cable
multifuncional porque yo no tengo un
lenguaje tan moderno yo creo que hoy en
día a los más chicos les voy a tener que
preguntar cómo se podría llamar un cable
transparente que no vemos y que la
información sube y baja ya ahí está el
filtro radar ahí está el medio cerebro y
ahí como ven el radar captó el ojo yo me
dije a mí misma y por qué para hacer la
conexión con ese ojo que vi para mi
cortometraje y aquí como ven puse
agregue un torrente ya lo que yo le
llamo torrente que muchas otras personas
le llaman de otra forma es nuevamente lo
que hablaban los griegos eso de la musa
inspiradora o de la inspiración divina
por fin lo entendí mientras le contaba
esta historia a mis amigos ya mi familia
entendí que es algo
que uno lo siente y el dios sentirlo al
vivirlo lo reconoce
y me di cuenta que yo ya lo había usado
antes
entonces cuál es la diferencia porque
vengo a hablar de esto ahora y no antes
y yo desde chica que vengo dibujando o
haciendo películas agarrando imágenes
que yo no sabía de dónde venían pero las
integradas mi trabajo la diferencia es
que lo hice consciente y al hacerlo
consciente uno puede elegir entonces uno
puede abrir esto o no ya las cosas no
vienen al azar sino que uno puede ir
rastreando
entonces esto me hizo pensar a mí no
solo en mi proceso creativo pero también
yo como persona porque se me abre todo
un mundo ahora
y al darme cuenta que existe todo esto
que es mucho más grande que yo en el
fondo me puso un poco en perspectiva
entonces hice este dibujito pensando en
qué pasaría si el metal cerebro está en
la misma distancia que la luna de la
tierra por ejemplo entonces yo me veo
desde allá a mí misma
y me di cuenta que era minúscula de
hecho no me veo no aparezco en el mapa
no me alcanza ni para extraer la
película de la vida
entonces al principio me dio un poquito
de miedo porque yo dije no pues yo soy
alguien tengo un nombre tengo familia
soy guionista y directora soy todas
estas cosas
pero de a poco me fui dando cuenta que
en realidad era un alivio
porque yo dejé de tratar de controlar
las cosas biocidas deje de tratar de ser
la autora de algo tratar de
de dirigir cosas que no estaban en mis
manos porque nunca estuvieron en mis
manos siempre fueron parte de algo que
vino antes que yo iba a seguir hasta
después de que yo me muera
entonces me hizo ponerme en perspectiva
y esto al verme de tan arriba
me hizo recordar que no somos los únicos
protagonistas de esta película están los
animales y las plantas
entonces dejamos de ser nosotros los más
cool de esa película y los protagonistas
sino que nos damos cuenta que estamos
conectados con otras cosas y para mí
llegó a través de las abejas
o sea me di cuenta de esto porque en una
película que estoy escribiendo ahora que
vendrá en un futuro cercano
mientras escribía invadieron miles de
abejas ya digo al papel en el guión
mientras escribía llegaron la abeja una
escena y como yo ya estaba más o menos
con esto
con este filtro radar ya funcionando las
dejé entrar
obviamente entonces a medida que yo
escribía las abejas mismas me fueron
escribiendo el guión de alguna forma yo
no tuve que seguir inventando cosas
porque ellas venían con toda una
información
entonces bueno aquí tengo un dibujito
que hay copia textual una parte del
guión y al lado aquí derecho es como yo
imagino una de las partes que la que
llega a las abejas pero en el fondo de
nuevo no fui yo la autora
yo no estoy siendo solo la autora de
este guión y no seré sola la autora de
la siguiente película
y esto me ayuda darme cuenta que al
investigar un poco más
me conecté un poco más con la naturaleza
paso que voy a volver atrás con las
abejas una de las cosas que me llamó
mucho la atención y que quizás mucho
ustedes saben pero yo no lo tenía tan
consciente es que mucha
las abejas tienen una forma de
comunicación son seres super sociales y
tiene una forma de comunicación que
podríamos decir que es casi telepática
ya porque se comunican a través de sus
antenitas y no necesitan como nosotros
conversar
y que fue algo que yo debí haber sabido
pero no lo tenía tan consciente entonces
eso me hizo agrandar un poco mi
curiosidad y seguir tratando de entender
la naturaleza que nos rodea que muchas
veces nosotros no nos detenemos ni a
mirarla
entonces con esto en mente me di cuenta
que no sólo esto era una herramienta o
algo para mi creatividad sino que era
una filosofía de vida
y antes de irme por las ramas porque
y mucho
estas son algunas de las preguntas que
nos podríamos hacer ya quiénes tienen
acceso a este meta cerebro porque ya he
hablado de todo esto pero entonces ahora
a lo concreto
como ya dije antes algo que existe fuera
de nosotros y estamos conectados pero
existe fuera por lo tanto no está en
nosotros y nosotros nos morimos esto va
a seguir todos tenemos acceso eso es
algo que existe por si mismo es
y limitado es inmortal en el fondo
entonces todos tenemos acceso a nuestro
cerebro yo creo que desde siempre
solamente que a veces se nos cierra esto
y no nos damos cuenta
entonces ya pensemos que todos tenemos
acceso como abrirlo como estar conectado
con eso yo mi filosofía lo que he
aprendido es que
es a través de la práctica lo que lo que
realmente hace que integremos la
experiencia por lo tanto yo no les puedo
decir cómo hacerlo cada uno tiene que
encontrar su propia forma lo que yo
puedo hacer es si compartir como yo lo
he hecho una de las cosas que me ha
servido mucho es el silencio
están en silencio un par de minutos al
día a la semana o como quieran empezar
ayuda ayuda a estar con me ayudó a estar
conmigo mismo me ayudó a entender o al
menos como explorar me a mí
sin caer en el día a día que no que no
nos mete en esa máquina
el respirar
me di cuenta que no sabía respirar hace
muy poquito de hecho empecé a respirar
de nuevo algo que me llena mucho de
alegría también es buena parte de la
gente que yo quiero es estar en la
naturaleza
la conexión no es solamente no lo pongo
en papel no lo dibuje un arbolito porque
es lindo sino que yo al estar sola en la
naturaleza en silencio me conecto se me
abre de nuevo ese filtro otra de las
cosas que hago o que me gusta caminar
correr mover me hace que me conecte pero
nuevamente estas son cosas mías cada uno
tiene que encontrar su propia forma
agregué esa pregunta cómo se siente
estar en el torrente porque alguien me
la hizo una vez se siente como una
cascada de agua
pero ahí de nuevo depende de cada uno
pero es una sensación
interesante y creo yo digna de explorar
y es por eso que yo creo en esto ahora
porque creer en todo esto nadie tiene
que creer en esto obviamente no viene
aquí a predicar nada la idea es que cada
uno crea a través de su experiencia yo
creo en esto quizás más adelante voy a
creer en otra cosa no lo sé pero ustedes
tienen que creer creo yo en lo que uno
comprueba por sí mismo finalmente eso
y porque creo yo que es importante haber
venido hoy a hablar de esto
porque me preguntaron cuando me
contactaron los de ted que tenía que
decir que sí que tenía algo y dije tengo
sólo esta idea pero no sé si quieren
realidades
la gente quiere escuchar o es importante
no sé
pero a mí me enseñaron que desde muy
chica yo vengo una familia muy grande
muy numerosa y siempre fui parte de
grupos
y me enseñaron desde chica a compartir
me enseñaron a compartir lo bueno
y he aprendido en mi vida que cuando uno
comparte información que ayuda que nos
eleva que nos hace un poquito más
felices
y entonces no dejamos de separarnos
nos juntamos
y en el fondo entendemos que somos todos
todos parte de una misma gran película
que yo le podría llamar
estamos todos tratando de hacerlo lo
mejor posible y yo creo que esa una de
las formas en que yo puedo aportar desde
mi área es el cine pero de nuevo como
viéndolo ya como una filosofía de vida
ya no es algo para yo hacer mi película
sino que ahora entiendo a través de todo
este proceso que lo que yo hago al final
no es para mí
y espero que lo que yo ponga afuera
cree algún espacio de imaginación o crea
algún espacio donde
las personas los animales las plantas
todo lo que está aquí se conecta
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]